my view on critical race theory is not i
think i'm for bands but i'm also for
actually
attacking the institutions that promote
these things like i'm
uh this is why i have the idea of
eliminating student loan debt by taking
it out of university endowments which
yes kill two birds will chamberlain has
been screaming
endowments for some time no it's totally
true i mean but also ngos like i think
ng
non-governmental organizations have made
a kind of racket out of promoting
critical race theory
i think these also should be should be
they shouldn't exist
i want to show this graphic from this
this cartoon from political humor on
reddit
it says then and there is some you know
white man
bearded with a confederate shirt and he
says we must preserve our heritage and
there's like a confederate statue of the
flag
and says now and it's the same guy
ripping up a piece of paper that says
critical race theory
and he says we must bury our heritage
and then
on the blackboard he's in a school it
says 1921 tulsa massacre
and there's a cop writing lesson banned
it's like
it's all it's almost as on the nose as
ben garrison's comics
and there's like sad little kids of
varying races looking at him doing it in
the sad you know black teacher and i'm
like
the funny thing is they rely on false
arguments in an effort to push back
as if james lindsey is a confederate
like christopher ruffo
james and chris ruffo the most prominent
voices opposing critical race theory
have literally nothing and nothing to do
with
an old white man wearing a confederate
flag yeah james lindsay actually
in a moment of confusion attacked me as
a as i think a promoter of critical race
here because i made a joke about how
some latinos are like white adjacent and
he attacked me
he like attacked me because i don't know
i think he thought i was like a
critical race theorist or something but
uh no you're right
uh i think lin lindsay is one of these
guys who's i think he's he's just like a
liberal isn't he like
a classical liberal traditional he's
harmless classical liberalism is more
like libertarianism he's totally
harmless and yet
because he argued that look the logical
conclusion of telling people
that whites are the root of all evil and
are to blame for everything
in the words of susanne sontag if you
know who she is so that the white race
is the cancer of human history
if you tell this to people you're going
to start seeing an increase in violence
against whites
just like you would against any group
you know it's a cool acts
sure sure but you're also going to see a
rise in white racial identitarianism
of which critical race theorists are
actively calling for right now
well the the he had the weird deangelo
thing but
the point is is that when lindsay just
made this harmless
observation he was attacked uh as
promoting like a the white genocide
conspiracy theory right right right
right that's the weirdest thing but
wasn't it by quillette
yeah uh claire lehmann or lemon whatever
her name is
uh yeah well let's become like
particularly establishment
pro-establishment isn't it
very strange right yeah because it's
it's it's like adjacent to the idw
uh but i mean look the whole like
identitarian thing is
is if you're going to have a society
where you have the hispanic caucus
and the black caucus and every group is
allowed to have
an identity and as part of that a sense
of dignity
like it's okay for me to be black or
it's okay for me to be hispanic or
whatever
and you deny that to whites do you see
the problem with this
do you see the problem with having a
black caucus and hispanic caucus but
then you tell white people you're not
even allowed to think of yourself
in terms of of a member of a group like
it it's
uh it's a it's a kind of problem that
creates itself
so i think i'm not sure who but somebody
uh rather mainstream i think dave
ria boy yeah made this argument recently
like look you you
literally can't have this society it
will collapse on its own terms
and i agree with that one thing about
critical race theory i've been thinking
a lot about is
i see this push to ban it to make it
stop like stop make it go away
no no more no more that's not gonna work
because
i do agree that we shouldn't be
indoctrinating children with a racial
theory
in school but we need to educate people
about what critical race theory or
critical theory is
implicitly if we know what it is we know
what to look out for well hold on
when i grew up i was told by my teachers
classically liberal ideas
i was told not to judge people based on
the content of the character of the
color of their skin
the t the schools told kids this and it
was accepted
they said not to be um you know hateful
or homophobic and all that stuff
today the teachers are saying they want
the kids should
judge people based on the content of
their character i'm sorry they should
judge people on the color of the skin
not the content of the character
the point is even if you say we're
banning critical race applied principles
the teachers still will say these things
and still believe these things
that's it that's then they should lose
their in my opinion and fire them up
every single one of the teachers should
be held this is i fully support a ban
i support firing teachers that promote
this stuff i support seizing the
endowments i support
destroying ngos but financially no no
no no no no think about when when uh
you know the civil rights movement was
happening that it's
this is the the trouble with banning
ideologies religions can be defined we
know
you know religion there's an interesting
debate about uh intelligent design
versus
uh evolution and people are like
intelligent design is just religion
because it's not in science
the problem is you can easily make
something an ideology and then how do
you ban
it you talk don't tell the kids to
believe things about race you said
racial theory
well martin luther king jr's theory on
equality was a racial was was a racial
theory i don't i understand critical
race applied principles are are very
specific and it's
it's a specific ideology but how do you
ban an ideology how do you separate
ideology from public institutions you
need to educate people
about what it is first so that they know
that's a big part of it
um i think it is it is easy to say we
have the 1964 civil rights act
and creating racial groups is a
violation of of title i think what is
that
nine title nine in colleges particularly
i i would actually argue
that critical race theory is an
outgrowth of the civil rights era
and the primary function of crt today is
to explain
why disparities have persisted despite
the civil rights act sure but derek bell
opposed
civil rights derek derrick bell was was
critical of democrats
this this is where uh i'm i'm fairly
sorry i i
i could be wrong so fact man this one
but my understanding is that bell
was operating the idea that you know
democrats were effectively
uh taking agency away from the black
communities and forcing them to coexist
underneath i i got to go through the
literature specifically on bell but my
understanding is
critical race theorists effectively
oppose
civil rights and one of the things that
that i've seen emerge out of black lives
matter uh the black house matter
movement specifically
this was in i think ferguson ferguson
and baltimore was this idea that
segregation was a good thing
and these were black activists saying it
they believed that
before the end of segregation there were
equal and opposite communities
in which you had black families black
businesses black wall street
segregation forced the black community
to live underneath
the existing white infrastructure effect
you know make
effectively making them second-class
citizens i'm pretty sure that was a lot
of those ideas came from bell
yeah and that's why one of the one of
the big criticisms of critical race
theory is that
the goals of critical race theory are to
rewind
the clock back before the civil rights
movement so that's why you see things
like caucusing
they want racial segregation that's why
you see an attempt to repeal
california's civil rights provision in
its in their constitution
so that they would have the right to
discriminate on the basis of race
and other things it's why you see
actions from the left with harvard
they need the ability to discriminate on
the basis of race which means repealing
the 1964 civil rights act
they oppose it and they always have well
the thing about i mean this is
the thing about the cra is that it
actually has codified and
institutionalized discrimination against
whites
it has by and it has done that by
basically
advantaging and giving every other group
except for white
uh white's preference and access to
different affirmative action programs
in effect it discriminates against them
no no affirmative action it's actually
been argued a violation
of the 1964 civil rights act
particularly um
with harvard you cannot discriminate on
the basis of race
one of the ways they've gotten around
this is that the courts ruled this was
particularly recently in in southern
california
that so long as you offer up an equal
program for other groups it is not
discrimination
specifically if there is a woman women
in computers program
and um there was a man who sued they
said is there a men's computer program
yes okay it's not discrimination
the problem with that argument is the
the that's the argument for bathrooms
if you're offering up an open bathroom
to all then anyone should be able to use
any you know
i'm sorry it's if uh the
the problem with that argument is the
racial argument if you're creating
you know a whites only or you know a
blacks only area
providing free but separate access was
one of the critical arguments
from the civil rights area that ended
segregation so ultimately long story
short without getting too complicated
the critical race there is swat
segregation they can't have it so long
as the civil rights act says you can't
discriminate on the basis of race
so in california they had i think it was
proposition six i could be wrong
where they maybe it wasn't six i'm not
sure where they wanted to
remove from their constitution the
public
civil rights provision that said you
cannot discriminate on the basis of race
you know uh sex national origin religion
in
in schools in public contracting and
employment they tried to get rid of that
recently i think just this past november
it failed because people of california
were like why would we get rid of our
civil rights
yeah i think you can find these examples
of these situations where people can
successfully
i guess find recourse against this stuff
to the cra but i mean the fact is
is that affirmative action things like
that is actually the outgrowth of the
cra and i mean
but that makes no sense it does when you
consider that the
the provisions of the civil rights act
were intended to kind of like
were intended to let's say catch blacks
up and other
initially blacks but the provisions
ended up extending to
uh to homosexuals to immigrants and to
women but the reason
californ the democrats are arguing they
can't implement
these programs because of the civil
rights provisions i haven't heard that
argument
you need to read about the prop uh let
me see my point is is that you're
you're right there probably are these
instances where people say these things
but
generally speaking the legacy of the
civil rights act has been
the culture of affirmative action i
think and it part of it's confusing
because
people thought no it wasn't prop 6
that's that was road repair
people thought they were going to get
this colorblind thing
right and when you look at like the
rhetoric of mlk
you also see that there's the famous 16
maybe it was a famous quote judging
people by the content of their character
instead of the color of their skin
but mlk explicitly supported affirmative
action programs he saw no contradiction
between
something like the civil rights act and
affirmative action 16.
i was wrong it was it was proposition 16
proposition 6 was like the rhodes
repairing act or something like that
anyway um the it's it's called the
affirmative action amendment
federal level democrats came and started
campaigning on behalf of california
saying
california should have the right to
discriminate on the basis of race in
schooling and public jobs
for the sake of fixing racial
disparities
it uh uh it got 57 42 percent
42.77 voted yes on prop 16 in november
november 3rd 2020
57.23 said no
9.6 million people said no to prop 16
keeping california's civil rights
provision in their constitution
making affirmative action
unconstitutional in california
yeah no i'm not not denying that you you
have this example but i think you can
find plenty of counter examples one of
the reasons that the 1986 immigration
reform control act
was on it basically unenforceable was
actually because of civil rights act
because there was this problem where
businesses enforcing the provisions of
the immigration control reform act would
potentially run
up into anti-discrimination laws that
were part of the civil rights act
so this is it's like an unintended well
i think in some ways it's an unintended
consequence but it's it's the logical
conclusion of making
anti-bias in anti-discrimination the the
sen the central principle of your
politics is
well why are we why are we waging this
war against discrimination well it's
because one group
is discriminating against all the rest
and i'll say this too
there's almost no hard principle for
anti-discrimination so when we look at
the 1964 civil rights act
we ultimately will just make a personal
decision as to where we stop
if we truly believe you can't
discriminate against people based on
certain immutable characteristics or
certain personal characters or
characteristics or identities it goes
infinite yes that's right
furries uh new york says says gender
identity is self-expression by which
legally furries would be protected and
so ultimately
the 1964 civil rights act is really
about
society and what our social norms are
and are willing to accept thanks for
checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time